[Music]
all right let's go e45
we might diversify our openings a little
bit as we get to 1600 but for now we're
keeping the basics out he's already
stumped knight c3 we might have to play
against the vienna because i've
obviously played the vienna from white's
perspective a lot but not as much from
black's perspective so here you want to
go knight f6 right you can also go
knight c6 but it's more accurate to play
knight f6
okay d3 so this is a
i've seen this before um it's obviously
not not an ambitious system
and generally the way that i've seen
white play this is is going d3 and then
g3 because this of course closes in the
bishop
so clearly not something that we should
be afraid of
and essentially black can take two
approaches in this position the first is
sort of
the developmental approach we could just
go knight c6 whatever bishop c5 but we
can also take the sort of more
principled approach
and what do i mean by that what move
could we play if we wanted to to really
take it to white
for playing a relatively passive move
yeah of course we could play d5
and if you count the defenders okay one
two one two so if everything is traded
on d5 we already know uh from our time
playing the four night scotch that that
trade essentially benefits black
let's take the more principled approach
in this game let's go d5 much like we do
in the philidor with the white pieces
you know if white plays passively
we strike at the center now of course
the choice for our opponent is he takes
d5 or a move like knight f3 we'll see
what they do
he takes d5
okay knight takes d5 what am i waiting
for
knight f3
yeah so this is almost a reverse
four night scotch
with the move d3 thrown in
no of course
we want to go knight c6 here we don't
particularly want to take on c3 in this
position
you might say well doesn't this ruin
white's pawn structure well it kind of
does but i've talked about this
on many occasions this particular pawn
structure is really not that bad for
white uh why am i saying that because
after knight c3 bc
you're letting like control a lot of
these key central squares with uh with
their pawns
so there's no need to release the
tension
with knight takes c3
d2
very passive play by our opponent
yeah he's
playing this playing this passively
probably bishop d2 bishop e2
but this is actually quite an
instructive moment because
we need to decide
where to develop our bishops and i think
what a lot of players tend to assume is
that the more advanced the better right
so probably a lot of you are thinking oh
we should go bishop g4 and bishop b4
or maybe bishop c5 and bishop f5 but
that's not necessarily true in fact i
don't like the move bishop g4
why not because after
uh bishop b2
there
there's a certain tension that's created
between the bishops that actually
threaten something so after bishop g4
bishop e2
what does white actually threaten
very good guys knight takes c5 bishop g4
bishop b2 threatens knight takes e5 very
typical tactic
and so i'm going to make a move here
that most of you are probably not even
considering
we're going to play
i'm going to play bishop b7
and
i don't know how to make this point in
the best possible way but
the primary function of developing your
dark squared bishop
is to castle
you see what i'm saying so putting this
bishop on c5 or putting on putting in on
b4 is not particularly effective if you
put it on c5 you kind of run into the
move knight e4 or even knight a4 so i
quite like the positioning of the bishop
on e7
now by the same exact logic if we're
trying to play as solidly as possible
and develop our pieces on invulnerable
squares
where should this bishop go
bishop b6 exactly bishop b6 reinforcing
the knight and look how nicely our
bishops are stationed this bishop is
preventing the knight from jumping out
to g5 this other bishop is still on this
diagonal and it's reinforcing the knight
a3 yeah very very passive play by white
so we can just continue sort of making
improvements to our position
um what do i mean by that well what
low hanging fruit can we pull out here
and actually the move a3
it potentially prepares b4
it potentially prepares b4 so you know
i've changed my mind i actually don't
particularly like allowing b4 uh because
if white plays b4 then he's going to be
threatening b5 and then our e5 pawn
might get a little bit weak so
let's play a5 let's let's prevent
let's prevent b4 let's try to put the
squeeze on white can we open the center
here well we already kind of have
i don't really know what you mean by
that i mean you can't really go e4
so we don't need to worry about doing
anything else to the center
uh we can certainly play the move f5 i
see a lot of you were suggesting f5 i
was actually thinking in a different
direction
um i was thinking in the direction of
going queen up to d7 in order to connect
the rooks
and prepare potential sacrifices against
h3 in the event that
our opponent castles so but of course f5
is also a completely legitimate move
the only thing that i don't always love
about playing f5 is that it of course
very slightly weakens the e5 pawn
because later on you won't have the
possibility of going f6
queen c1
what is the purpose of this move
probably to prepare knight g5 would be
my guess
so yeah h6 or you know even the move f6
here i would even play f6
i would even play f6 because
not only are we preventing knight g5 but
we're also reinforcing the e5 pawn
i know what a lot of you are probably
thinking
is wait a minute like how do i know when
f6 is a safe move and when it's a
weakening move when should i follow ben
feingold's advice
well again as with everything of this
sort it's a case-by-case thing and when
your opponent is this passive think
about what it is that f6 actually
weakens mostly it weakens this diagonal
well does white have a bishop on this
diagonal can white put you might even
put a bishop on this diagonal no and no
so and
you know in addition we already have a
bishop on this diagonal so
if you just look at the position it's
quite clear that f6 doesn't really
weaken anything yet it closes the bishop
but again our bishop can always
reposition to c5
so i'm not worried about this bishop
being bad it's got plenty of space let's
go queen d7 now
let's go queen d7 we're eyeing the pawn
you guys are
obviously by now very familiar with the
bishop takes h3 type of sacrifice which
is why you shouldn't play h3
nonchalantly in such positions
especially when you're very passive you
can fall victim to this kind of
sacrifice
and
whoa h4
this is i mean i have to say white is
playing badly but it's not that easy to
punish this because white is actually
quite solid
hmm so
when you see a move like h4 which is
incredibly strange
it's important to approach it
methodically and ask yourself well what
specifically seems to be the drawback of
this move what exactly is this weakening
because all of us are looking at this
move and saying that's weird but let's
be more specific than that well what is
exactly is it is it doing
yeah so it weakens the g4 square if you
think about the action of playing h4
well it weakens the g4 square
is that important well it might be
because now we can put a bishop on g4
and guess what that bishop on g4
cannot really be attacked by a pawn
now didn't i previously say that i
didn't like putting the bishop on g4
well yes i did but the circumstances
were different then
if you remember we didn't have a queen
on d7 why is that important because the
queen on d7 is going to be reinforcing
the bishop on g4 what else is different
white's queen used to be on d1 the queen
on d1 x raised the bishop now the queen
is on c1 so we don't really have to
worry about any knight takes e5
related
tactics does that make sense so this is
a good example of being concrete right i
didn't like bishop g4 earlier but now
this move
puts the bishop on really an outpost and
we could even play h5 ourselves i'm not
ruling that out we absolutely can play
h5 ourselves
just to secure that bishop to strap it
in completely
and here's the thing
white is so passive here that we can get
away with a lot of stuff that otherwise
we wouldn't have been able to get away
with so a move like h5 under a
completely different set of
circumstances i probably wouldn't even
consider
here i i just judge that white doesn't
have the capacity to exploit a lot of
these weaknesses windy one is not a bad
move
okay
so we have a couple of options now white
is not threatening anything
actually he is
he is threatening knight takes e5 if you
think about it and i'll show this after
the game
but knight takes e5 is a tactical threat
here which wins upon
so
the logical thing to do would be to
defend the bishop
yeah i kind of like f5 so we played f6
in order to
defend the e5 pawn but remember that
white has already played h4 so the
benefit of playing f5 the downside of it
is that it weakens the e5 pawn but the
benefit is that it reopens the bishop
let's play it
and it puts immediate pressure on this
h4 pawn
it puts immediate pressure on this h4
pawn the reason knight takes e5 was a
threat is because after knight takes c5
he plays bishop takes g4
you know don't worry about it i'll show
it after the game put it out of your
mind right now let's focus on the game i
promise that i'll show it afterward
g3 whoa
more weaknesses created on the king side
another understandable move i mean white
is reinforcing the h4 pawn
but again whenever there's a pawn move
like this we ask ourselves well what
does it weaken well in this case it
weakens the h3 square so the move bishop
h3 comes to mind but what exactly does
it accomplish well after rookie one i'm
afraid that it doesn't accomplish all
that much
i quite like
the positioning of the bishop on g4
so i think that rather than jumping to
conclusions and doing anything drastic
i think that we should
we should simply improve our position
well f4
but but f4 still allows knight takes e5
folks
f4 still allows knight takes e5 because
it removes the defender on our bishop
and that leads to a highly complicated
position which and i don't want to allow
such complexities
now when i say improve my position what
do i mean by that well we can think
about which aspects of the position we
can reinforce
one thing i've previously mentioned is
the pot on e5 is a little bit too weak
for my taste i want to be able to move
this knight without having to worry
about losing the pawn
what nice way do we have of improving
that pawn without without reducing our
general piece coordination
not bishop d6 folks because that
blunders the knight that severs the
connection between the queen and the
knight
not bishop d6 but bishop f6 bishop f6 i
think is a nice move defends the pawn
and now we can bring the rook to e8
slowly but surely we can perhaps prepare
e5 to e4
um
a lot of you guys are proposing
the immediate rookie which i also like
but i think this move is more flexible
because maybe we can put our rook on d8
right you always want to start with the
most immediate and the most flexible
move here we're reinforcing the pawn
with the least value piece and i always
say that do
if you can accomplish a task with a
bishop
rather than with a rook then you often
should you want to keep your most
valuable pieces for the most important
tasks
so that's actually a very
seldom talked about rule is that you
have something you want to accomplish
you want to defend upon you want to
maneuver a piece somewhere
do it with the least value p so that you
can leave your rooks and your queen
for more important stuff so i i love
rookie e8 now
i love rke8 let's do it let's get our
rook into the game
completing essentially
uh the picture we have perfect peace
coordination
now we can start thinking
gradually about taking more concrete
action such as f4 or e4 but we don't
have to hurry with that at all
okay knight g1
yeah strange play by our opponent right
she won is
pretty solid move i have to say
uh offering the bishop trade
now we have a bishop trade
potentially
um no this position i see somebody
saying i would beat magnus from this
position white's position is not that
bad and the reason i say that is because
as passive as white's position looks
uh he doesn't really have that many
targets right everything is sort of well
defended this kind of style is not that
easy to play against even for me okay so
should we take the bishop or not
and again i keep tricking you guys
because i asked the question you say no
just because i asked yeah we should take
it because if we allow white to take on
if on g4 then what square are we going
to give white at the end of the line
we're going to give white a very
important square for one of uh their
pieces
which is the e4 square for his knight
knight is going to come to e4 so
unfortunately we have to part ways with
our bishop but that's okay
but that's okay
well it gives up the e4 square i'll show
this after the game
i'm surprised he's thinking knight g2
should be automatic
knight g2 is gonna follow and then we
can start thinking about our response
and i might have to speed up just a
little bit because
um i can anticipate this being a bit of
a longer game
queen takes you to wow
very surprising
very surprising queen takes e2 well this
seems to walk
right into knight d4
although the queen i suppose can drop
back to d1
i mean let's go let's put our knight on
d4 i can't resist that i'm sorry i can't
resist knight d4
and you know
i think this question gets asked of me a
lot is like how do you know
when to make these general improving
moves
and then when to press on the gas pedal
and go for a win well again a lot of
people asking that question are hoping
for a a formula or an algorithm and i
can't promise anything like that nothing
like that exists but you just kind of
get a feeling you get a feeling like
okay i've made all these improving moves
i i need to start pouncing like the time
has come and i'm getting that feeling
now so what does it mean to press on the
gas pedal here how can we
start playing more concretely against
white's weaknesses or we can try to play
f4 yeah the move f4
definitely comes to mind as a way to
start breaking down
white's defensive construction on the
king side
now might think about this and say wait
a minute doesn't this
give up this monster square on e4 and it
does but i just feel like
you can't make an omelet without
breaking some eggs and i feel like
you know that's not the most important
part about the position yeah we do give
up the e4 square but hopefully our
attack
is going to be worth it
okay
no this guy's good i have to say this
might backfire on me the way that this
game is going i i don't have a good
great feeling about that things
so
i'm gonna make a confession here i
had in mind a bishop sacrifice that i
thought was winning but i just realized
that i missed something
which honestly
puts into calls into question the
strength of f4
now ideally we would want to advance
this pawn either to f3 no ideally we
want the f file to be open
now for the f file to be open we need to
move our bishop out of the way this
bishop on f6 is in the way right now do
you guys see what i'm saying it's it's
interfering with the rook
get it out of there just shoo away
remember that the bishop is a long range
piece which means that it's doing the
same thing from d8 that it was doing
from f6 this is a concept a lot of
beginners in particular struggle with
this bishop is aiming at h4
just as effectively as it would have
been doing from f6 so do not be afraid
to make retreating moves with the queen
and the bishop because they are long
range pieces that's exactly what they're
meant for to make to attack from behind
c3 great move
where should our knight go
where should our knight go
well our knight should go somewhere such
that it continues to exert some sort of
pressure on white's king side well let's
survey the squares clearly knight f5 is
the only logical move
because it's
you know now you can start thinking
about potential peace sacrifices bishop
takes h4 being one of them
uh and you can also potentially start
thinking about a rook lift rookie 6 or
g6 although if you look carefully rookie
6 unfortunately is not possible
due to knight c5 with a fork so maybe a
little bit later maybe after b6
where to put the queen if opponent goes
knight c5 queen c6 and blue queen c6
i don't understand why knight c5 is so
scary just queen up to c6
okay some of you okay goodnight equine
f3
now this is a high level statement
but i noticed something interesting
about this position do you guys see the
queen and the rook being unforkable
square so my brain immediately goes 93.
now obviously there's a pawn on f2 i
know that
so then i think what if we play f takes
g3 f takes g3 knight fe3 that wins an
exchange
well it doesn't you have to calculate
further than that how can white try to
save the exchange after knight e3 who
can tell me really quickly because we're
going to make this move anyway
actually no we're not there's a
beautiful oh my god there's a crazy
tactic there
we can play going f7 oh we are going to
we're are gonna play it there are some
crazy tactics there queen b3 so why can
play bishop take c3 knight takes e3 and
then queen b3 check now we're gonna play
this anyway oh please knight takes g3
yeah but now
now our move is very simple now the
attack has paid specific dividends
now the attack
the attack we can cash in for something
finally something specific
well not bishop h4
why why bishop h4 because then he takes
on f5 and takes an h4 knight h4
yeah knight h494 bishop h4 now we're up
a pawn the king is kind of in shambles
and now i feel more confident queen h5
is probably the best move for white but
we'll deal with it we can always just
drop our bishop back to d8 that is one
hell of an exposed king
you guys probably see that knight f4 is
a very much a potential idea for black
yeah
because bishop takes f4 e takes f4
chases the knight out of g3 and the
knight on g3 is essentially the last
defender good move
let's get her let's get our bishop the
hell away again
shoot the bishop get back right
notice i'm absolutely unafraid to make
these retreating moves with my bishop
because i don't want my bishop the last
thing i want to do is put the bishop on
f6 where it's going to be in the way of
the rook so do not judge moves based on
how much they retreat a piece that's not
a metric that i use to judge whether a
move is good i don't care whether it's
retreating over and advancing though i
think that whole concept is overrated
if i may be honest this whole oh it's a
retreating move i've had some students
who've had
a lot of struggles with just retreating
moves and i've tried to tell them like
don't think of a move in those terms
think of a move based on what it
accomplishes
rookie one
well what should we do now i think now
we should follow through with our
general plan i've already kind of given
away the move
well i don't like rookie 6 folks
because it doesn't threaten rook h6
because there's a bishop on d2 so i
think after rookie 6 white can actually
take on e5
instead i think the time has come for us
to reposition our knight to f4 and
essentially force bishop takes f4
and if he moves his queen then the queen
comes to h3 with mate
can white play queen h4 no because we
have a little bishop here on d that's
guarding that square
it's our fu thank you for the prime now
ooh
we can take with the rook here and try
to lift it to h4
but
there is a specific reason why i don't
like that and there's a specific reason
why i like taking with a pawn because
it's with tempo it attacks the knight
and if you look around the board you
might also see that the d3 pawn is
hanging so
potentially we could try to take that
pawn we could also try to lift this rook
to h6 on the next move
this is looking very grim for white so
for instance if white plays 94
notice that we have eliminated white's
bishop on d2 as a good practice anytime
a trade happens take a couple of moments
to ask yourself to refresh your
understanding of ideas which ideas are
now possible which ideas are still
impossible so the idea of a rook lift
now is a lot more appealing but
amazingly rookie six still doesn't work
this guy's so resilient
rookie six is still bad for another
specific tactical reason what is it
and queen takes d3 also fails to another
tactic
god damn
it there's a fork rookie rookie 6 walks
into knight c5
um queen takes d3 walks into a discover
check knight f6 check
and that line goes on but it doesn't
work
hmm let me think
so
i'm going to try to walk you through how
i think about this position well
what is the sexiest idea that we have
probably rookie six or kitchens right so
this is the one that we want to prepare
i care a lot less about taking this pawn
than i do about lifting this work i want
to get this workload to move well why
doesn't it move why doesn't it work well
because
of knight c5 so can we prevent knight c5
let's go b6 let's at least try it
i hope i'm not blundering anything here
because
he's got ideas here for sure but i think
our king is safe
i mean chess can be a very logical game
if you just go through the process of
just thinking about a position and think
about what you want to accomplish and
why you can't accomplish it there's no
reason that you can't make moves like
this
i think a lot of people they look at a
move like b6 and oh it's like a typical
gm gm move but it has a very specific
logic to it
i identify my top priorities in the
position
then i ask myself can i accomplish them
identify obstacles and voila
those obstacles i make them disappear
let's go
let's get our rook in motion now
this is not so simple folks
you might notice that rook h6 is not a
threat because of his excellent last
move
why not because if queen takes h6 and we
will not be able to recapture because
we're pinned
okay but he moves the screen it's a moot
point
okay let's go a rook to h6
okay
so
the queen f3 was amazing actually
yeah now i think
now i think he found the best way to
deal with our attack the thing is king
f1 is not a threat because of rook h3
and then we're gonna win d3
i think that we should
probably take this opportunity
to make a some sort of general improving
moves such as bishop e7
or maybe king h8
this knight is really good i'm
struggling to find a particularly
satisfying maybe c5 just expanding and
fixing the pawn on d3 i like the move c5
let's go c5
let's go c5 in order to prevent d4
do you see why i'm doing that to keep
this pawn weak
and then the bishop could even
reposition to c7 later perhaps to defend
this pawn if necessary
now you might look at this and say well
wait a minute doesn't it create
weaknesses it doesn't it create a
backward pawn on b6 yes it does
but
as we climb in rating i want you guys to
to start thinking of this more as a tit
for tat like chess is a big game of tit
for tat okay you make this concession
uh but you gain something in return so
don't just stop there say oh well this
gives this up so we shouldn't play well
that's not necessarily true now here
rook h1 is another great move we should
go back to g6 we should at least keep
our rook alive
okay now i have a follow-up idea ladies
and gentlemen which is to
get this rook onto d8 so that it
pressures the d3 pawn
now in order to do that
we have to move our bishop out of the
way so i think the time has come for us
to play bishop e7
yeah we could have also played bishop c7
but i want to keep this bishop relevant
i don't want it to be staring at the
pawn yet
getting back to e2
i'm also kind of getting outplayed here
i'm gonna be totally frank
let's go queen b5 let's hit the pawn of
b2
you see underrated he is very underrated
yes
very very underrated
how does it drop the f4 pawn we have a
rook on f8
okay now
we're gonna hit him where it hurts with
c4
and i'm playing a little bit faster here
because i've got three minutes the point
of this move
i want white to play d4 so that the
knight on e4 loses the support of the
pawn my plans have changed rather than
going after the pawn because the pawn is
so well defended i now want to go after
the knight
i want to go after the knight
now how am i going to go about doing
that well one thing we can do is put the
rook on e8 rather than f8 so that it
x-rays the knight on e4 then we can try
to move the bishop again and create a
pin does that make sense
so by playing c4 i'm provoking d4 which
i assume he's going to play
then i'm going to move my rook from f8
to e8 and i'm going to put the pressure
on the knight
yes it gives up the f4 pawn but i care
less about this pawn i think then we can
move our bishop out of the way and we
can create serious problems against his
knight concretely
like rookie a rookie six maybe rookie
six is actually the best move after d4
okay actually now that somebody pointed
this out rookie six
rookie six might be the way to do it
this might be the secret sauce
let's do it let's play rookie six wow
instantly
okay let's get our queen
to f5 maybe just to attack the knight
that's right i did learn mayonnaise
okay so we're attacking this knight i'm
anticipating
rook bf1 this is the test of whether
this guy watches the stream
nifa thank you for the prime
and kevin
41 months
okay let's go ricky
very good doubling rooks
wait a minute
what if we i don't really have a minute
but what if we play bishop takes a3 give
me a second
should be three wreckage five
queen g6
no it probably doesn't work
q5
rook takes e4 though oh bishop takes a3
i don't see a refutation to it
i can't i don't see a refutation to
bishop takes a3
okay
let's make him prove it
i'm sure there's something but let's
let's see what it is
you want anyway
okay well why don't we just move our
bishop back
this is a very strange player
i've never seen to be play like this
okay we're gonna we could have taken the
pawn on b2 but i don't want to adventure
i want to keep our bishop safe yeah
understood make sense
just want to keep our bishops somewhere
near our king
i didn't want to take b2i i didn't know
what was wrong with that move but it was
it felt too risky king c1
yeah but now we're up two puns now i'm
better
now you know what i think we should do
folks is go
i think we should go king h8 here
just to get our king
outside of the range of any potential
knight checks on f6
so for instance a move like d5 now is
not dangerous because we could just take
the pawn whereas earlier he would have
had knight f6 check as a follow-up
winning the queen
prophylaxis yeah
then maybe we can play h6 to create some
lift because by playing king h8 we
walked right into a potential backrank
problem
that should also make sense to everybody
we've walked into a potential background
problem so if only we have a chance to
go h6 i'll be happy
okay goes there
now i think we should trade everything
and go b5 to defend the pawn on c4 let's
do it
let's go b5 and let's defend the pawn on
c4 this should make a lot of sense to
everybody
what we're doing here
and now it's going to be close because
this pawn is extremely dangerous and our
position is very very passive but we
have one big asset in this position
oh that looks like a really bad move
wait a minute that looks like a terrible
move
queen d3 looks interesting let me think
that's definitely wrong
no i think we just take it folks
i think we can just take it
yeah but oh my god it's so tricky
actually
hmm
i'm gonna take it i'm gonna explain why
after the game
i promise
i'm gonna explain why after the game
what i'm gonna take here simply
i i know
it it's a weird decision but
now i'm gonna go a4
start pushing this pawn
yeah i know guys i know they're tempting
moves just hold on please
i will explain it after the game right i
promise
this doesn't worry me and you know what
we're going to do now
let's start pushing the other pawn let's
go h4 h3h2 boom boom boom now you might
say well why am i not pushing this pawn
well he's got a knight on e1 that's
going to be blockading and i feel like
i'm pushing the pawn that's furthest
away from his knight so i feel like this
pawn has the highest chance of actually
promoting probably our hardest game of
the speedrun assuming i win he resigns
but it's a pretty generous resignation
geez
strange strange game i'll be completely
honest
i guess just the style of play was was
weird like white was playing like a i
heard somebody somebody say like a
tortoise
and that's kind of true like he was just
hunkering down very close
keeping all the pieces so close
and it was very hard to break through
it was very hard to break through
um
okay
so
let's go over the game
i don't know i've never really and i'll
be honest i've never really seen anybody
play like this
very very unique style i guess like
bishop d2 very passive opening
bishop b7 yeah no
no groundless accusations like i said i
think he's legit i think he's underrated
and
i i don't know what to say it's just a
strange style we'll leave it at that
folks
we don't have to discuss this any
further we can still enjoy the game and
derive instructive value from
it um
so
this should be two bishop b6 so this is
yeah
guys remember
i'm like 1500 plus now we're not
expecting people to just roll over this
is a 15 minute time control i'm
expecting people to start playing quite
well
now
it's also the way he played is
definitely strange but strange doesn't
automatically mean that he cheated
okay
a5
um preventing b4
queen c1 f6
why is it passive when he goes bishop d2
and it's principled when you go bishop
b7 asks dearest mother that's a great
question so
um that seems like a contradiction am i
contradicting myself by saying this is
passive while this is not passive no so
here's the thing when i say that white
played passively i'm not just referring
to this i'm referring to the overall
scope of light's moves it all starts
with the move d3 if you really want to
know what's passive this is the passive
move because it blocks the bishop
and it's the combination of the moves
that white plays like here here bishop
d2 and bishop e2
if you just compare our setups right
we've got a bigger chunk of the center
the bishop on e7 is a cog in the machine
it's preventing the knight from coming
to g5 whereas the bishop on d2 and the
bishop are just kind of sitting there
right and also he's playing white and
when white plays like this
it's just undoubtedly passive when black
plays like this it's it you know black
often gets more of the benefit of the
doubt when you play passively because
it's a defensive setup but with white
you're just not supposed to play like
that
okay
so first important moment ladies and
gentlemen is after queen d1 we wanted to
establish why knight takes c5 was a
threat so let's take
a random move such as
not rookie rook d actually defends
against rook e8
so the reason a lot of you were arguing
with me is because he said after knight
takes e5
bishop takes g4
knight takes g4 it looks like the queen
defends everything but it doesn't the
queen is overloaded guys knight takes d5
you should see this this is pretty
elementary my dear watson
queen takes d5 queen takes g4 and uh
white wins the pawn
okay so
any time you have a bishop on g4 and
bishop on e2 and the bishop on g4 is
undefended i literally mean it anytime
there's a bishop on b4 and bishop nd2
remember that the knight can move away
it can take something you have to watch
for that entire
suite of tactics
right this is where
well what if knight takes e5 knight
takes c3
um
then i thought knight takes d7
knight takes d1 bishop takes g4 and
white is winning because everything is
hanging
so this is how how you develop pattern
recognition you sort of remember oh this
has happened i need to check for these
kinds of tactics and
as i've shown many times before even
strong grandmasters
tend to miss this this sort of stuff
this is from one of my games against an
im i've shown this game before watch
what happens this is a classical game
against the 2350 fiji
so bishop b7 queen e2 knight f6 guess
what movie plays here bishop g5
now what did i do in this position now
do not just automatically say knight
takes before actually think about it
this is a classic this is a classic
blunder
very good
very good it takes d5
and this is a concept you just have to
know
um
and the point is that
if he takes on d5 then we take on g5
and a bishop takes e7 that that very
same knight takes that bishop and we're
upon and he might say well why does
knight takes d4 bad i take c4 doesn't
win a pawn because what white does here
is plays knight takes c4
now you can't take the bishop because
that very same knight takes the bishop
but after f64 white first takes on e7
well obviously you have to take back and
after f takes e4 white is fine
understood so both knight takes d5 and
knight 64
has to be
uh monitored
now does that mean you should never put
your bishop on g5 or b4 of course not
that's not what i'm saying just got to
be careful i i know a lot of you
probably have blundered this before
okay so that's why we played f5 we
played f5 to reinforce the bishop now on
to the next important moment
so
knight g1 was an excellent move actually
this one i underestimated
queen's 82 was very strange
and let me tell you
[Music]
what my oversight actually was so i
thought
that i could sack the bishop
and then play the move f3 and from a
distance i evaluated this position as
being at the very least a lot of fun to
play
now what is the zen behind the sacrifice
what is the purpose of this
well the purpose of this is to play
queen g4 as i'm sure everybody sees
and to deliver the lobster pins to
checkmate on g2
but what i miss here
is the very calm knight h3
and after knight h3 queen g4 white isn't
time to put a rook on g1 and black's
attack fizzles there's just look at this
there's nothing to attack with
and white has gotten a lot of pieces
into the defense the bishop coming to g5
and unfortunately
with this monster knight sitting on e4 i
think black is running out of gas
so
i mis-evaluated this i thought we could
stack on h4
and so we end up going bishop back to d
which is actually a very good move i
think
organin says that's still winning are
you sure about that i don't think it is
i don't think this is still winning i
think this is very unclear
i mean for instance
unless you're looking with an engine
then i stand corrected
um but
and even bishop g5
forces the queen back now you can go
knight g3 and force the queen back even
further
no ogden you're i think respectfully i
disagree after knight three i think
white is better
white is better
no he's 1400 blitz
yeah no this doesn't work
this doesn't work
um and it doesn't work because you don't
have enough attackers so we end up going
bishop d8 c3 knight drops back to f5 to
pressure these pawns after knight f3
very important
to um
obviously to pay attention to i've told
you this a million times forkable pieces
any time you have a situation where you
can get a knight onto a forking square
and again even if there's a pawn on f2
you have to pay attention to that
because you never know how the situation
might change
now i was fully expecting
this to happen
and now as many of you indicated white
can get out of the fork
by playing queen b3 check and here
there's a amazing moment
i'm going to give you guys a very
difficult question
how should black play
and if i calculated this correctly
there's only one correct move here it's
a trick question
there are some incredible tactics here
now you're in check folks you're in
check how should black react to the
check
actually i think there's two possible
moves but they're very similar in their
ideas
so
essentially let me walk you through
how i thought about this position
oh
the first thing that i notice here is
that
white's rook is kind of f'd because if
white goes rook f2
then the knight swings back to g4 with a
fork right so
and the rook cannot go to e1
because we simply take the knight on f3
now i know we're in check so it it
follows from that logically that king hh
should be winning
but king h8 walks into a brilliant
tactic
and the ingredients of that tactic is
the weak back rank
the fact that there's a queen on b3 and
the fact that there's a knight on f3
white can play knight takes e5
now you might say well let's
take the rook with check and then we can
take the knight but no because of rook
takes f1
and hopefully everybody can see the
issue
which is that if you take the knight you
get backrank mated
if you take the rook then you lose your
queen and if you move your queen
then you walk right into knight f7 check
and um
this is at the very least good for white
i mean you probably have to take this
knight otherwise you're going to get
destroyed
so having calculated that
rather than abandoning the whole line i
said wait a minute what if we covered
the check and then i spotted the move
queen f7 this is a simple movement
forces a queen trade
obviously
nothing to speak of here white has to
trade after rook takes f7 that's it we
eliminate the danger
and because we attack the rook we win an
exchange
rook f2 there's still knight g4 check
rookie one there's still rook takes f3
simultaneously defending the knight
understood so
because of these tactics i think this
works out for black
knight takes g3 knight takes h4
now i think our opponent correctly gave
away the pawn rather than the exchange
and
i will
show you one moment where the computer
indicated i made a mistake
why does it force a queen trade asks
crow hour let's go back
so crawler asks no it doesn't you're
right
you're absolutely right in fact white
should play queen takes b7
but what i meant to say is if white
wants to try to avoid losing an exchange
white should trade queens he i agree
that white's best approach is to
accept that he's losing an exchange and
take the most for it that he can
um
but
what i was saying is like if y wants to
try to avoid losing an exchange then
they should take on f7
okay
so
knight g3 and h4
knight f4 we forced the trade now we
played b6 to prevent knight c5 and here
after rookie six queen f3 wreck h6 and
g2
i missed a far more decisive approach to
the position so i decided to play it
slow and just start start making surface
level improvements but there was a
very counter-intuitive move here that
led to a far more decisive advantage and
that was g5
instead of b6 try f3wtf
as in white and what kind of idiot am i
not to play it
um
okay and f3 is so strong because
like let's say rook g1
i guess rook f4 no but then knight f6
yeah probably f3 was better
so
but i played b6 because i really wanted
to lift the rook up
of course this is winning after you go
aboard you know i'm not not saying this
isn't winning
um and perhaps f3 is better i'm not sure
what point you're trying to make
so
here the move g5 is very strong we want
to play g4
and
essentially we're forcing king f1 but
now we have this old move rook h3 which
i mentioned which wins the d3 point
um
so that was
something i completely missed i didn't
oops sorry
i didn't even think about g5
like i i
didn't realize that this pawn goes so
fast i didn't want to weaken my king
like this
just shows you how how good computers
are
g5 just weaken your king like this and
go for g4
okay so c5 rook h1 we don't trade rooks
we get our bishop to a good square queen
b5 is a nice move attacking b2
why is king f1 force because
if king f1 isn't played then we're going
to go g4
now you might be wondering why is g4 so
dangerous well let's make a random move
well after g4 white gets steamrolled and
queen f2 you get forked
and of queen d1
in
black can even go g3 here
and then start do you see how dangerous
this is the queen coming to h3 white's
whole defense of construction has been
dislodged and destroyed
so a lot of you are indicating i don't
have access to the engine in uh live
but apparently he had some way to draw
after queen b5
i don't think that's quite as important
i think black retains an advantage we're
up upon
you know we're probing and poking and
prodding
and i think this move c4 is very strong
because we're
isolating and weakening the knight
now we're immediately
re directing our attention on to
attacking this knight
um
king d2
queen f5
hitting the knight again
now we pile up the pressure
and boom bishop takes a3
bishop takes a3
um ogden you're making a lot of
categorical statements i wouldn't be so
sure
um apparently i made a blunder a little
bit later you guys are saying
oh my god
no oh my god that's amazing
king eight shade is a blunder because of
knight d6 look at this
and i did say that our back rank is weak
and i didn't see any background tactics
i did see this move
i did see this move
i swear
what i calculated
was that after the trade
this is not checkmate we have queen g8
who sees what i'm missing
who sees what i'm missing
i played a move automatically somewhere
in that along that line
yeah you don't have to take on e6 white
gives a check first
now is this mate
no bishop f8
but wait a second takes takes
takes queen g8
yeah and queen takes f4 and because of
white's protected passer i think white
is doing okay here
because white has this nasty passer
white is fine this is a draw
ridiculous line i
i knew this concept existed but man i
just didn't think about it and by the
way if rook takes c2 folks another very
important detail white to move who can
tell me the best move
who can tell me the best move
yeah knight d6 is a draw for that reason
it equalizes
not take f5 don't grab the queen just
because you can black has two rooks for
the queen no you take on e2
you see why because now black is forked
and you can only get one rook for the
queen
so yeah sorry king h8 was a blunder
should have probably played h6 first i
should have probably made some luft
initially
so in an attempt to play
prophylactically ironically i actually
walked into a tactic
um
oh and apparently i'm being told that a
little bit earlier after rookie 8 white
had the move knight g3
which is a less impressive move because
i saw it i mean i just thought i'd go
queen f7
so i'm not sure what it is exactly that
is so dangerous about this but
probably the computer will indicate some
stuff
i mean you guys and this is an a message
to people watching on youtube as well
uh you're welcome to analyze these games
with an engine i mean
you will unlock a lot of stuff that i've
missed
i try to present the speedrun virtually
without engines to give it the most
instructive value but you can derive a
lot of your own instructor value by
analyzing the engine find my mistakes
figure out why they were mistakes and
you can learn that way so don't limit
yourself to what i say
check my conclusions with an engine
bishop takes a3 does this move make
sense to everybody exposing the attack
on the knight
ricky one
and maybe we could have taken b2 i don't
know maybe perhaps the engine will say
that too
but
well if if it's not a bishop sack guys
bishop
b takes a rick takes c4 it's not a sack
it's just a discovered attack
it's just an easily discovered attack
against the knight
back to f8
king c1
king h8 missing knight d6 but after
knight d2 this allows the rook trade
now we defend the pawn and now we're up
two pawns
and our plan here ultimately is to push
the h1
after b3
a lot of you were screaming
bishop a3 check i was about to play this
move
why didn't i play it because after king
d1 first of all this is not checkmate
ladies and gentlemen this blunders the
queen
i know what you're thinking you're
thinking c takes b3
knight takes b3 queen b wants
but white's not going to take on the
knight and that's why i rejected this i
was worried about this move i was
worried about this move
if you cover with the bishop then white
can take on b3
now
if the queen starts gallivanting around
well the bishop's gonna be hanging in
the end so you're not getting very far
so you can cover the queen but amazingly
after queen takes b5 i just wasn't
convinced that this is the most
convincing way we can play
like i just didn't know whether this was
entirely clear because this spot is weak
white's got protected passers now
again i hope this makes sense but i just
wasn't
confident this is
the most clear-cut approach
and so ultimately that's why i decided
simply to take and play a4
but here i think white missed
his last chance to complicate the game
which was to play knight c5 this had to
be played white has to keep the knight
active
the point is that if you take twice you
get back rank mated
one other very important point hess
makes this point all the time in queen
end games you can have a single pass
pawn
and it can be 50 times stronger than
like five other past pawns and this is a
great example of that you might say well
we can just play h5 and black is two
pawns up but
look at where white's pawn is white's
pawn is already on c6 so perhaps even
white is playing for a win here
so here we would have probably gone
either a3 or h5
but it's still it's still a game
okay
at a1
and after h5 he resigned which is a
totally valid resignation this is over
we're just pushing our pawn all the way
down to h1 there's nothing i can do
this d-pawn is not going forward
the game is over
um
corollary yeah maybe queen c5 stops the
pawn i'm just trying to make a general
point about this end game not being easy
to win
in general queen end games
are
one of the hardest end games to win
because of the
amount of trickiness that exists in them
so regarding the engine
um also to the youtube crowd i
i really i strongly advise against
watching with an engine
now i can only advise again for su
because that defeats the whole purpose
and you have plenty of opportunity to
see how much i suck when i play blitz
like you can follow an engine you can
see me making mistakes on every move
you already know that like i play like a
human and i make lots of mistakes
but you gotta ask yourself like why are
you watching and when you watch with an
engine i think you
immediately remove all of the instructed
value because it is then impossible to
actually understand what it is that you
can figure out on your own
now i said you can use the engine for
instructive value but i'm talking about
after the game like after the game once
you've analyzed it on your own if you
want to take a look with an engine
i think that's a great idea but
i would say if you want to like maximize
learning then you should just shut off
the engine entirely and try to embrace
embrace the suck you know embrace the
fact that you
might struggle with some of these
positions
and you might not understand something
and mistakes might go unnoticed
this is a great game a lot of uh and
there's a lot of stuff i didn't talk
about like i could i could talk more
about the opening
but
ultimately there's going to be many more
speedrun games good night thanks for
hanging out bye
[Music]